The days of Television being seen as a smaller,
cheaper, or less ambitious sibling to movies
are long gone, as some of the best writers,
actors, and directors are turning their talents
to the small screen.
But they’re also required to churn out countless
hours more every year – for fans, that means
plenty of tiny mistakes and laughable errors
you don’t want to miss.
Here are Screenrant’s 10 Huge Mistakes You
Have To See In TV Shows.
Breaking Bad
Creator Vince Gilligan’s story of a chemistry
teacher turned drug kingpin was carefully
planned, which means major mistakes are hard
to find.
As the show built towards its second season
finale, Walt was forced to break into his
partner Jesse’s house, and steal his stash.
With Jesse and his girlfriend in a heroin-fueled
haze during the visit, it must be a crew member
awarding himself a hard-to-miss cameo, peeking
around a door frame as Walt makes a fast exit.
Orange is the New Black
Complicated doesn’t begin to describe the
relationship between Orange is the New Black
heroine Piper Chapman and her ex-girlfriend
Alex.
Aside from being the one responsible for landing
Piper in prison, fans could have seen early
on that Alex wasn’t to be trusted based
on her tattoos alone.
The first episode of the Netflix series gave
a clear look at the salt shaker on Alex’s
left shoulder that would last for the rest
of the series.
Or would it?
Two episodes later, it’s changed its position,
returning to its original angle from then
on.
Mad Men
Creator Matthew Weiner knew that setting a
TV series in the early 1960s would mean plenty
of fact-checking, but Mad Men has been noted
for several mistakes and inconsistencies.
Gadgets that weren’t invented yet, or modern
sayings are on thing, but Weiner has admitted
a few are more embarrassing.
When Joan mentioned a reservation at the famous
New York restaurant Le Cirque, food buffs
called foul, since it didn’t open until
1974.
The creator first blamed actress Christina
Hendricks for ad-libbing the line, but would
later admit it was an oversight, and a “terrible
error.”
Game of Thrones
It didn’t take long for Prince Joffrey to
prove he wasn’t born to lead once he took
the throne in the fantasy series’ first
season.
Among the most surprising twists was releasing
Barristan Selmy from the kingsguard without
warning.
The proud knight didn’t go quietly, forcing
the rest of the king’s knights to draw their
blades.
No blood was spilled, but the standoff was
enough to rattle one of the guards, as one
can clearly be seen shaking and struggling
to sheathe his sword without ruining the entire
shot.
In hindsight, the humor probably helped break
the tension in the throne room.
House of Cards
With Frank Underwood having climbed to the
rank of Vice President in the first season
of the Netflix original, the second season
finale saw him claim the Oval Office for himself.
To do it, he sends a typewritten letter to
the president, offering to take the fall for
his scandal.
Using an Underwood typewriter raises the drama
of the scene, but it also means Frank lets
a typo slip through.
Although he narrates the letter as “staring
at the desk,” the letter clearly shows the
word “started.”
Where’s spellcheck when you need it?.
Better Call Saul
Fans of Breaking Bad were all too happy to
see an origin story of attorney Saul Goodman,
but the timeline meant it would have to be
set in the year 2002, with Breaking Bad taking
place seven years later.
The show runners did a good job of keeping
new model cars and technology out of the fiction
– but they weren’t perfect.
The background of one scene includes the AT&T
logo.
It’s actually the logo introduced in 2005
– in 2002, the sign should have featured
the company’s previous logo.
Sons of Anarchy
The boys of SAMCRO may have won over fans
with their criminal adventures, but masterminds
they’re not.
That usually isn’t a problem, but it also
means that Opie makes more work for himself
than he has to, breaking into a car in the
second season.
He’s using a slim jim properly, sliding
it into the window casing to pop open the
lock.
But from the interior shot, it’s obvious
that the car is already open, with the door
lock shown in the raised, unlocked position.
Homeland
Every movie and TV fan knows that no matter
how intimate or personal a performance or
scene may be, there are dozens of producers
and crew behind every camera.
But it’s the director’s job to make sure
that the casual viewer never actually SEEs
them.
Sometimes, that’s easier said than done.
For instance: an episode of Homeland that
required a Saudi diplomat be interviewed in
a window-filled building in broad daylight.
The scene may be gripping, but it’s hard
to not be distracted by the entire crew reflected
in his glasses against the sunny background.
American Horror Story: Freak Show
Jessica Lange’s leading lady Elsa in season
2 of the TV series had a more tragic backstory
than most, having lost both of her legs.
Her prosthetic legs are hidden under stockings
for most of the show, until the series finale.
When her dream of superstardom is briefly
dashed, Elsa collapses to the floor in hysterics.
Apparently, the editors determined there wasn’t
any point in pretending her legs were prosthetic,
simply hoping fans no longer cared about keeping
up appearances.
Modern Family
It’s not really fair to criticize the Dunphy
clan for their mistakes, since Phil’s flawed
thinking is what made him a fan-favourite
cast member to begin with.
He has his successes, though: like making
his family proud by learning to walk a tightrope
in Season 3.
He makes his dream come true by the episode’s
end but… it shouldn’t have been a dream
to begin with.
Two seasons earlier, Phil revealed he was
already an expert at the tightrope, thanks
to his time spent at trapeze camp.
Maybe all those knocks to the head finally
caught up with him.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite bloopers
or mistakes from hit TV shows?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.